i think about every episode
as being a different chapter and a
travel narrative
so what do i do let's go left right here
here
the book itself is is very patriarchal
because the main character is not the
most empathetic of
individuals and he's somebody who wants
to sort of rip his family away from the
clutches of the 20th century and all of
its commercialism and materialism and
take them
to a new eden we're going to chase the
weather out of mexico
to where mexico sip some tequila go
swimming
go fishing you don't need enough fish
you need to eat more food we don't even
know anyone there
the tv show employs this couple this
family of four are not making a choice
to leave but they're on the run
neil cross is the shepherd and guardian
of the scripps
he came up with a really good device of
basically knowing that there needed to
be
something at the backs of the foxes
meaning this government agency that
sort of chasing them out of the united
states
let's go
visually what we've tried to do is to
show that two very different worlds
one that was very clean and fluorescent
and then an outside world
in the case of where they headed there
was much more unordered
unpredictable the colors more of a kind
of blend of different influences and
sources
we're more often than not quick to judge
what a migrant is
and and in this instance it's a white
nuclear american family
going into a wholly different culture we
take them from
this is their environment this is their
life and we take it
all away from them we gotta go
you